I never wanted to get married when we
were younger romance seemed simple so my
place or yours
I always thought that by the time I got
married I would be different hey that's
too sheeter and then suddenly
Oh Chris is going to propose to me
so Oh stone um I can't really hear you
call me back when you have better
reception just need some time to think
about it yeah I'm not saying she's a
lesbian
but most girls are dying for this Nora
begged me to marry her and she was a
lesbian before all this you guys were
doing green right women give men all
Tomatoes all the time maybe he's right
you're not gonna let him extort a yes
out of you are you it's not extortion an
ultimatum is an acceptable form of
negotiation extortion is illegal what
[Music]
I'm gonna propose to him didn't your
boyfriend be the one doing the proposal
you tried and you said no yeah sort of
silly drink know how he hit you what no
no but if I don't know how long I'm
gonna need it's okay
I just can't die four years younger now
Oh
[Music]
you